[Music]
if you stray outside the designated
areas you will be removed from the
island
it's recommended you wear a hijab when
visiting your client we've had incidents
of inmates spitting at female lawyers
you want to represent the head recruiter
for 9 11.
muhammadu al-slahi the mauritani is held
in guantanamo
you recruited the guys who flew your
friend's plane into the south tower
he put those men on my husband's plane
i'm gonna make him pay in the event the
detainee lunges for you push back away
from the table we'll get in there as
quick as we can
[Music]
i'm nancy hollander this is my associate
we wish to represent you
we are seeking the death penalty but if
we miss something this guy goes home
let's get to it call this bumper speak
to my mother
tell her i don't know something nice
the u.s government is holding upwards of
700 presidential guantanamo
since when did we start locking people
up without a trial in this country
that's a lot of case styles the
prosecution won't show us the evidence
they have against you
it's all redacted you had a problem take
it up with the government
all my time here i've been told you are
guilty
not for something that i have done but
because of suspicions
and associations i am innocent he has
been interrogated he has been held
against his will
for six years without a single charge
being laid against him
doesn't it bother you at all working for
something like this i'm not just
defending him i'm defending the rule of
law
you haven't seen what i've seen
where i'm from in mauritania we know not
to trust the police
but never did i believe that the united
states of america would use
fear and terror to control me a couple
suitable nights that's hot
i've never been part of a conspiracy but
i'm starting to think this is what it
must feel like to be on the outside
you're overthinking this either wear the
jersey or get off the field
you need to tell me what happened to you
i can't defend you do you understand
that
you asked me to set fire to this place
but i'm still
maybe he's guilty maybe he is we're
doing our job i'm not welcome home
that's not a part of my job
if i'm wrong when it comes to my record
and i'm the one that have to add support
what makes you think you're any better
than the rest of us i don't think i'm
better than anybody else that is
important
for eight years i have been dreaming of
being in a courtroom
now that i'm here i'm scared to death
you know i think i figured out
why they built guantanamo down there
michael he's not a suspect he's a
witness
mr slahi would you please raise your
right hand and repeat after me
the mauritanian
[Music]
you